嘿分享你一個
在媽媽圈裡
流傳非常廣的
止咳湯
就是蘋果洋蔥水
敲一敲 敲一敲 敲一敲
就這樣的喔
敲一敲 敲一敲
清肺瀉火
改善咳嗽氣喘
改善呼吸道
還有改善
胸悶胸痛
聲帶發炎等等
都可以緩解了
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
這一集要和你分享
肺健不健康
看這5症狀
感冒喝蘋果洋蔥水
真的有效嗎
喉嚨爆痛
按耳朵
2個穴止痛
1招檢測
你的肺健不健康
中醫說
肺主一身之氣
氣靠肺來輸送
帶動經絡和
臟腑的協調運作
一旦肺氣虛了
氣血不暢
抵抗力下降
全身就像失去動力
整個人就越來越疲憊
蛤?
那如何知道
自己的肺虛不虛
來小編我問你五個問題
看看你
有沒有肺虛的現象
各位粉絲
你現在也一樣的
檢查一下自己
有沒有肺不好的症狀
1 你的臉色蒼白
聲音小而又沒力
懶得講話的情況嗎?
有
我累的時候
真的會懶得講話
2 你會常覺得累精神差
動一動就很喘嗎
最近整個人
好睏喔
3 你是那種一吹風
就得感冒
或者是好怕冷的人嗎
我很怕冷
冬天手腳
都像冰棒一樣
4 你咳嗽會沒力氣
咳出的痰是白色的
清清稀稀的嗎
這個我沒有喔
5 你的舌頭顏色
是偏淡的
舌苔是白色的嗎
我今天刷牙的時候
有看了一下
舌頭是粉紅色的
舌苔是白白的
這樣有正常嗎
小編恭喜你
你的肺
還算是健康的
各位我剛才講的
這幾種症狀
如果你都有
就要注意自己的肺囉
如果只有三個
有問題呢
那也得注意啊
自己的健康
要自己照顧吧 不是嗎
像現在的天氣
是變來變去的
人家感冒了
你就跟著感冒
常常覺得喉嚨痛
人家在咳嗽
你也跟著咳
注意囉
這很可能就是
你肺氣不對勁了
也許就是肺氣虛了
會讓氣血運行差
抵抗力也會變差喔
如何讓肺健康
來馬上教你一個
手上的穴位
叫做魚際穴
這就是肺經的穴位喔
打開你的手掌
掌心靠近拇指
這個位置的顏色
假如說靠近拇指的顏色
比較白白的
肌肉隆起來
這個地方呢
就稱之為大魚際
就在這裡啊
而拇指根部
與手腕連線的中點
這個穴道
就叫做魚際穴
來我們來敲一敲
這個穴位
你一邊聽我說
一邊用手
輕輕敲一敲
這個魚際穴
敲一敲 敲一敲 敲一敲
就這樣的喔
敲一敲 敲一敲
清肺瀉火
改善咳嗽氣喘
改善呼吸道
還有改善
胸悶胸痛
聲帶發炎等等
都可以緩解了
每次至少
要敲打30~50下
那才行
像這樣敲敲敲敲一敲
敲一敲敲一敲
我們說
五行生剋原理
這樣敲一敲呢
能養肺生津
而且呢
因為金生水
所以還能夠生腎水
肺氣足就能滋養腎水
這就是中醫所說的
金水相生
金生水
能夠緩解口乾舌燥
真的耶
都感覺嘴巴
有分泌口水了呢
那有沒有什麼食物
可以養肺
感冒喝蘋果洋蔥水
真的有效嗎
感冒啊
喝蘋果洋蔥水有效嗎
有
像這種天氣變化大的
忽冷忽熱的
這個時候
喉嚨就會癢癢的
有鼻塞啊想咳嗽啊
嘿分享你一個
在媽媽圈裡
流傳非常廣的
止咳湯
就是蘋果洋蔥水
只要這兩樣東西
蘋果 洋蔥 切成丁
丟到電鍋裡頭
煮一煮
就是一杯潤肺止咳的
咳嗽剋星
顧好你的呼吸道
據說蘋果洋蔥水
從阿嬤時代
就開始流傳了
看來蘋果洋蔥水
人氣很旺耶
哈哈
當你出現咳嗽的時候
是肺氣失衡的警訊
這個時候呢
不是靠壓制
而是要靠調理
蘋果洋蔥水
就是很棒的
調養的飲品
蘋果 潤肺生津
還含有各種多酚
能抗氧化 抗老化
提升免疫力
連感冒 流感
所有的病毒
都不敢靠近
洋蔥呢
能幫你
把體內的寒氣散掉
鼻子呼吸道
就暢通了
肺打開了
咳嗽自然就少了
不是嗎
這一杯要喝多久
才有效果呢
你連喝1週看看
肺氣一通
咳嗽好了
氣色也紅潤了
精神回來了
有三種人很合適哦
1在冷氣房
待一整天的人
經常咳嗽乾癢
又咳不停的人
2一吹冷風就咳嗽的
3有白痰又清稀的
動不動就喘的人
這三種人
肺氣虛最該補啦
具體的做法呢
小編會在影片後面
詳細的跟你分享
比例和製作過程
要記得看到最後哦
吃什麼養肺
3白色食材
清熱化痰
吃什麼可以養肺 少咳嗽
其實不用
什麼高級的藥材
市場就買得到
山藥 銀耳 白蘿蔔
這三樣都是白色的食材
白色食材
能夠滋陰生津
調節肺氣
幫助你修復肺部的組織
養肺 潤喉 化痰
顧好你的呼吸道
山藥能補肺氣
降血糖 降血脂
名醫別錄裡頭記載哦
山藥的功效
止腰痛
羸瘦
吃久了可以
耳目清明
身體輕盈
有腰痛
體虛的人
耳朵眼睛不好的人
吃涼拌山藥
山藥排骨湯
都很棒哦
中醫說啊
肺主皮毛 喜潤而惡燥
銀耳 富含膠質
能夠滋陰潤肺
解乾咳
就像天然的
肺部保濕霜
肺不好的人
你煮銀耳的時候
要煮到膠質
都釋放出來
就是喝起來
已經有點
稠稠的黏黏的
補肺才夠力哦
如果你有痰多
喉嚨癢的問題
就是肺裡頭的
濕氣堵住了哦
來
吃一碗白蘿蔔湯
能清熱化痰
順氣止咳
喉嚨痛到說不出話
快按耳朵的2個穴
你有喉嚨痛到
快講不出話
嗓子就像
被刀片割過的經驗嗎
有耶
真的好痛苦哦
醫師
你可以教我們如何
快速消除喉嚨痛嗎
沒問題
我教你耳朵2個穴道
簡單快速
能夠解喉嚨的疼痛
第一個穴是治療
像吞口水會痛的
按叫做咽穴
它在哪裡呢
是在外耳道的上方
大約就是12點的方向
這個穴叫做咽穴
你按一按咽穴
就可以止這個痛了
第二個
你氣管和喉嚨疼痛嗎
假如是的話
按一按喉穴
它就在咽穴的旁邊
大概就是
11點到10點鐘的位置
這個地方
好
在這兩個穴
你按一按揉一揉
那什麼叫做咽
什麼叫喉呢
在解剖學上來看的話呢
在喉頭這個地方
咽就是食道的最上口
喉就是氣管的
最上口那個地方
那麼當你吞嚥不行的時候
是食道上口的問題
當你呼吸不順暢的時候
是氣管的問題
這就分辨出來
什麼是咽
什麼是喉
當你喉嚨痛
痛到吞口水都痛的時候
你用手指按壓
這兩個穴道
你按的時候
會有點疼痛
那就對了
也就是按對地方了
按個1～3分鐘
很快就能止喉嚨痛
我記得我在二十多年前
曾經患過一次甲狀腺腫
就是咽喉這裡發炎
在這裡按一按
然後在甲狀腺來按一按
是咽喉發炎造成的
甲狀腺的問題
那你就按咽喉這個地方
就可以把你的甲狀腺的問題
也解決了
1動作補肺氣
晚上看東西也都清楚
再給你一個Bonus
如果你咳嗽咳不停
眼睛又會老花
我教你一招
養生導引法裡頭
有一篇叫做眼目門
這有什麼好處呢
方法就是
伸左脛
屈右膝
納壓之五息止
意思就是說
把你的左腿伸直
然後右腳彎起來
然後身體往前壓
深呼吸1次
兩次
一直到5次
這個動作能夠補肺氣
除去氣虛
引發的眼花
視力模糊
你經常做這個動作
幾個月之後
甚至於
晚上看東西都能夠
跟像白天一樣
清清楚楚的哦
這個動作看起來像抽筋
怎麼能讓眼睛變亮
好問題
中醫說
風為百病之長
氣虛擋不住風邪
眼花 頭暈 咳嗽都全來了
這一招其實就是
眼睛的氣血加油站
幫助你
通經絡
逼寒氣
養肺
又能讓眼睛看得更清楚
五十歲之後
最該做的事不是吃補藥
是養好肺氣
讓自己的視力更好
每天做1分鐘
肺氣足了
氣色紅了
眼神亮了
身體更有精神
蘋果洋蔥水的製作步驟
1.將兩顆蘋果和一顆洋蔥
切成小丁備用
2.準備一個大碗
把空杯子倒扣
放在碗中央
3.將切好蘋果與洋蔥丁
均勻鋪在杯子
四周的碗內
4.外鍋加500cc水
5.蓋上鍋蓋
啟動電鍋
6.蒸煮過程中
杯子會自動吸入
7.完成後取出杯子
杯中就有
蘋果洋蔥水囉